-President Trump has fired
Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson,
which brings us to a segment
we call "Couple Things."
-First thing...
Tillerson found out
that he was fired
from a Trump tweet.
Even when you get fired from
Dominoes, the manager takes you
into that crappy little office
and tells you to your face.
Tweets are for finding out
which band is in town
or which airline was mean
to Chrissy Teigen.
And, of course, Trump didn't
fire Tillerson to his face,
just like he didn't fire
James Comey to his face.
Basically, if you're
over 6 feet tall,
Trump wants no part
of giving you bad news.
That's why he's jumping at the
chance to meet with Kim Jong Un.
"He's how short? Oh, I'll look
like a giant next to him."
Second thing...
I'm not saying Rex Tillerson
was a great Secretary of State.
He had the energy
of a 14-year-old bloodhound
on his third mint julep.
He always looked like he was
walking through a fart cloud.
But if you're gonna fire
competent secretaries
for being bad at their jobs,
let me refer you
to Betsy DeVos' appearance
on "60 Minutes."
Not only was she wildly
uninformed,
but "60 Minutes" is also
her longest work day so far.
Also, a side thing,
why fire Tillerson today?
Well, just yesterday, Tillerson
said the attempted poisoning
of an ex-spy in London "clearly
came from Russia
and that the incident will
trigger a response."
Hey, just don't -- He just
didn't know the response
would be, "Clean out your desk."
Third thing...
hopefully what we're seeing
with the resignation
of Gary Cohn and the firing
of Rex Tillerson
is the end
of this myth that serious people
can reign in Donald Trump.
If the White House is
a fraternity in an '80s movie,
Tillerson was the dean,
and the dean never wins
in an '80s movie.
"Now, listen up, Delta house,
I'm going out of town
for a business trip, and I don't
want trouble while I'm gone."
"Oh, sure thing, Dean Tillerson.
I promise.
I promise we won't do anything
to get you fired."
Final thing, the only thing
more puzzling
than people agreeing to work
for Donald Trump
18 months ago are people
who are agreeing
to work for him now.
I mean, I get the first few
ninjas who thought
they could take down Uma Thurman
in "Kill Bill,"
but what was the last guy
thinking?
"Oh, I get it. If I come at her
from the right.
Also, I'll yell first."
And don't get me wrong.
I do feel some sympathy
for the Cohns and Tillersons
of this administration,
but in the same way
I feel sympathy when someone
gets attacked by a gorilla
at the zoo.
And that my first thought is,
"Oh, that's horrible."
And my second thought is,
"Why'd you go into the [bleep]
gorilla cage?"
This has been a "Couple Things."